- [Announcer] If you want to
travel by Amtrak from Houston
to San Antonio, Texas,
you only have one option,
the Sunset Limited, a long
distance train making 22 stops
from New Orleans to Los Angeles.
It only runs three times a week
and according to Amtrak
is over an hour and a
half late on average.
Compare that to the Northeast,
where 40 Amtrak trains link Philadelphia
to New York every day.
Amtrak has said for years
that it wants to replicate this model
in fast growing metropolitan areas,
like San Antonio, Phoenix, and Atlanta.
But over the last 50 years,
the rail network has
remained largely unchanged.
So why hasn't Amtrak expanded?
- So the biggest problem for Amtrak
in areas outside the Northeast
is that they don't control their own fate.
They're running along
tracks that are owned
by the major freight
railroads of the country.
- [Announcer] If Amtrak
wants to increase service
it needs to negotiate
with freight carriers.
But those companies
have long resisted calls
to make more room on their
tracks for passenger trains.
- Really, this just comes
down to an inevitable tension
when the freights and passenger
railroads have to share
a limited capacity of track.
- [Announcer] The only
area where Amtrak owns most
of the tracks is in
the Northeast Corridor.
- For that reason,
and because it's much more
heavily a passenger corridor
they're able to run a lot more
trains much more frequently
and that's why you see the
ridership in the Northeast
that you don't see in
other parts of the country.
- Amtrak has been renting
tracks from freight companies
since its inception,
that's because freight
rail used to move goods
and people on its tracks.
But by the end of the 1960s-
- They were running outta money
and they were in particular
losing money carrying people.
- [Announcer] So in 1970,
Congress bailed out the railroads
and created Amtrak to relieve
freights of the obligation
to provide passenger rail service.
Part of the deal was that freight trains
would give Amtrak right
of way on its tracks.
- Although the law requires
them to get out of the way
and practice, they don't.
- [Announcer] Amtrak blames
freight rail for its delays
saying passenger trains have to wait
for freight trains to pass.
According to Amtrak,
freight rail caused
passengers nearly 15,000 hours
of delays in 2021.
Part of the problem is
that freight carriers
run longer trains, some
stretching over two miles.
- If the train is too
long to fit all the way
onto that small siding,
then you're still gonna be in the way
of whatever train is behind you.
- [Announcer] Amtrak says,
freight rail not only prevents it
from operating trains at higher speeds
but also makes it difficult
to add more trains
by demanding excessive
capital investments.
- The freights and their
advocates in Washington
can get pretty frustrated about
the passenger rail advocates
not taking seriously enough
the work that they are doing
because so much of the
nation's commodities and goods
are moving around on the rails.
- [Announcer] Privately
owned freight companies
spend more than 20 billion each year
maintaining and improving their tracks
according to the American
Association of Railroads,
a trade group that includes
Amtrak and freight carriers.
The group says Amtrak and
freight rail share the same goals
of providing efficient
and reliable service
to both passengers and freight
customers across the country.
- This is train 125.
- The freight railroads also say
that they do a better job
making way for Amtrak trains
than Amtrak would make it sound.
- [Announcer] But if the
law requires freight trains
to give priority to Amtrak,
why hasn't that been enforced?
- There really are two reasons.
One is that Amtrak has been
essentially fighting to survive
for most of its history,
fighting to survive both
because there are people in Congress
who would've loved to
have it just go away.
Also because they just struggled
sort of budget to budget
to just keep the lights on.
- [Announcer] That's partly why Amtrak
hasn't bought more tracks
from freight railroads,
because it would be
prohibitively expensive.
- And also the freight
railroads need these networks
so they would not be in the mood
to give up any of this trackage.
- [Announcer] The second reason Amtrak
hasn't really been successful pushing back
against freight companies
is that there hasn't been
a good legal structure
for Amtrak to assert its rights.
- There was a railroad regulator
called the Interstate Commerce Commission,
which was winnowed down
and eventually eliminated.
The ICC sometimes did take actions
to improve passenger traffic
but it was spotty over
the history of of Amtrak.
- [Announcer] But things
started to change in 2008,
Congress passed a law that directed Amtrak
to help develop a set
of metrics and standards
to rate the on-time
performance of its trains.
- This would be a way to
measure whether Amtrak trains
were delayed in a way that
they're not supposed to be
by freight trains.
- [Announcer] After
years of legal wrangling
that led all the way to the Supreme Court,
the on-time metrics took
effect in October, 2021,
which gave Amtrak the ability
to begin building its case
against freight railroads.
In December, 2022,
Amtrak filed a complaint
against Union Pacific Railroad,
its first ever use of the 2008 law.
In its complaint, Amtrak seized
on that Sunset Limited line,
its most delayed route in the country.
- This is a sign of how
aggressive Amtrak is becoming
about trying to enforce its rights
and being willing to pick a big fight
with the freight companies.
- [Announcer] A Union Pacific spokeswoman
said the Sunset route is a
critical Union Pacific artery,
and it is essential that
Union Pacific and Amtrak
collaborate to design a
schedule that is reasonable
and achievable.
The other big change in Amtrak situation,
the 2021 Infrastructure Law.
- This law is the most
significant investment in rail,
the most significant investment in rail
since we created Amtrak
about 50 years ago.
- [Announcer] The railroad
received $22 billion
in direct aid and will also
have access to $44 billion
aimed at boosting passenger rail service.
- They are still and
will always be reliant
on federal subsidies
but their balance sheet is much stronger.
They are replacing cars and locomotives
at a rate that's much higher
than anybody has seen.
- [Announcer] In 2021, Amtrak
released its 15 year vision
which includes improving
25 existing routes
and adding 39 new ones across the US.
Imagine trains connecting Phoenix, Tucson,
and Southern California, Dallas,
Houston, and San Antonio,
and Nashville, Atlanta, and Charlotte.
Amtrak says this proposal
is a starting point
but the Federal Railroad Administration
will help determine the final plan.
- They've done a lot of market research
over the past few years
about whether there's demand
for passenger rail like this.
They also have been doing
a really aggressive job
of courting local officials.
Amtrak points to that as
evidence that this will work.
- Every study shows you you
get from point A to point B
on rail as faster than
you can on automobile.
You don't take the car
you get in the train.
- [Announcer] But to make sure
customers keep choosing rail
over other transportation options,
Amtrak says it's new service
can't have hour long delays.
The key to success,
a new arrangement with
the freight railroads.
(upbeat music)